hello how's it going find a way out of
the house take away the valuables so I'm
a burglar in this game where it says
don't play with dolls I'm a burglar oh
okay well what kind of things am I gonna
burgle well I'm real slow
all right well op I'll play with dolls
if I feel like it and how will I know
when there's things of value nice oh do
I have boobs hell yeah oh hell yeah I've
got boobs oh look at me hey how's it
going there either that or I've got
incredible pectoral muscles but I think
I got boobs hey how's it going there
anyway we've watched a let's play that's
gonna be entirely shot from a downward
angle Oh
press e to open Oh I snuck in through
the Attic that makes sense okay all
right okay hmm well why did I go in this
place in the first place
why did I do this I'm just gonna be
honest it seems like a bad idea all
across the board is there gonna be some
jump scares in here it seems like the
type of game that would have a lot of
jump scares I mean I'm just gonna go out
on a limb here and say that there's
going to be tons of jump scares I didn't
see anything of value not able to grab
anything it's not like there's any money
here am i here looking for something
specific
okay who's who's playing the windchimes
over there I don't like this Oh
looks like there might be some dolls in
here okay cigar box it's a blue triangle
NIDA then the other game I was playing
red circle they're all the things that I
needed in the other game anything in
here no there's nothing like what am I
even doing there's nothing that I can
interact with if I'm supposed to take oh
you know I just realized this looks like
the house from the game where you're
trying to steal valuables from the house
like like a thief something sneaky thief
something like that I can't remember
what it was called but you guys remember
that one right I'm not crazy
it seems oddly cheerful I think it's
trying to low me into a false sense of
security here and I don't like that okay
I still have no idea what I'm doing the
very organized thief that was it that
was it what I said was not it can I hide
in here okay so I can but what would be
the point of that I don't know why I
need to hide that's the first thing that
I've been able to interact with this
entire time I don't like this room this
feels like a bad room
oh oh okay moon something something
I don't get what I'm doing
also this seems very like different than
everything else that I was seeing in
this place so oh how lovely what was the
point of that what would will be when
the moon shines in the sky the traveler
will be protected
there's moon ones is that what I'm
supposed to do no what am i doing why am
I here why am i doing any of this what
does it all mean
thing isn't it yeah this back to the
kitchen what Phil this is all mean I
can't go in there
that's all locked up okay there's one
more place that I haven't seen and
that's this weird
oh this isn't even a door that's just
off its hinges what am i doing I was
told there was gonna be dolls I don't
see any dolls I've got a weird mannequin
ear with a bunch of moons I don't know
what the [ __ ] going on I'm lost in a
building no one's giving me any
directions I thought that was something
on the wall over there turns out it was
not got some matches all right oh oh so
there are parts there are things to take
well I wish I would have known that I
wish somebody would have told me that
what the hell how did so not tell me
that whatever okay so I gotta find these
blue pieces or something this is talking
about the moon right there's got to be
like a piece of a moon whatever it was
talking about so okay I just find them
wherever they are this is gonna be a big
hunt through the house wind chime
stopped as a matter of fact everything
stopped now I'm seeing
am I seeing something or is it okay god
I thought oh my god that scared the crap
out of me I thought I thought that thing
was two arms of someone dangling down
apparently not though okay so what do I
need to do so there must have been
something upstairs that I overlooked
because it seems like this was in more
of a readily available place and so I
was oh I don't think I went down this
way so I must have missed something
I like this yeah okay there we go wasted
a match but that's okay I found the doll
room well la-dee-da how are you doing I
can't open that maybe I don't want to
open that hey how you doing you good oh
you look good okay so you're not gonna
like sneak up on me when I turn my back
are you you're not just gonna like
murder me as soon as I drop my guard are
you oh here we go
o'clock pocket okay that was a bit more
dramatic than it needed to be okay so
what does this do nothing okay I don't
trust that it's just nothing the [ __ ]
was it
one of whoa whoa whoa what the [ __ ]
excuse you okay all right well that's
[ __ ] that's [ __ ] and you know
that's [ __ ] so don't play that
[ __ ] with me when you know that's
[ __ ] find the way out of the house
take away the valuables okay all right
fine then we're gonna do this again and
you're not gonna be [ __ ] to me
oh I wasn't even looking at my boobs for
good luck all right I'm looking for
valuables now I know what to look for
it's the small objects on top of tables
in this such as let's just go
immediately to the doll room and see if
we can do something about this hello
again how are you doing is it gonna be
the same thing up here yeah it's gonna
be the same thing okay grab this grab
that so that must be what starts the
whole experience here and I don't know
why oh there he is
okay so he's over there Ouisa coming
okay so if I go in here and I hide then
I should be just fine right she'll be
totally fooled hey buddy
Oh buddy where are you oh okay I guess I
win then whoa wait whoa whoa whoa hey
whoa listen listen listen listen
okay
[Music]
all right I had a lot of hopes for this
game it did set quite a mood at the
beginning of it now not as much now not
as much now not as much I'm gonna give
it one more go just one more go and then
we're gonna have a great time I think
because at first I was literally like
really good I'm getting oh I'm getting
chills down my spine here you know that
tingly wigglies about it and then Oh a
lot of nothing oh it's the same blade
good that's awfully convenient oh oh
there goes somebody help me
nobody I'll be oh my god okay so I don't
think there was anything else down here
I looked at pretty much everything and
it didn't seem like there would be so if
I bolt in there I grab the thing and
then I bolt out I should be fine right
really dude video video video and turn
this on for whatever that does
okay and then I'm out I'm Audi and I'm
down the stairs you'll never get me so
what does that do I don't even know what
that does okay all right I'm giving you
a shot here game impress me so I've got
this piece of like Halfmoon something
this has got to be this got to go
somewhere right or maybe it's just a
valuable me oh maybe this is I thought I
heard something
okay maybe not oh wait wait come on man
don't be dull come on you knew you clown
bastard get no go god oh god okay fine
you clown bastard so oh come on now you
sassy hand-waving piece of [ __ ]
where are you I've lost ya why are you a
pirate can I get out of here please
I leave can I hide is hiding even gonna
be were okay well know about
I paid money for this I think that's
good enough I think it's good enough for
that that's good enough right there
that's good enough right there let's
just move on we played it we gave it a
chance maybe there's more to the game
maybe there is more of the game I don't
know if I could find it I don't have the
patience for that but it's okay it did
set up good atmosphere it's just like
once that clown showed up a lot less fun
so we're gonna rework it gonna leave it
right there okay this one's called need
to pack it
I don't remember downloading this I
don't remember buying it just showed up
oh oh
restart day new job
it's money you want what do I need money
for Tyler let's just go easy to
difficulties easy and insane let's go
insane I don't know what I'm doing what
is this are you naked I'm gonna get
banned anyway or maybe these are my
boobs I don't know I can't be late for
work
today's the first day do I owe although
those were boobs alright don't know why
you were just standing in the middle of
your room completely but ask Nate what
is that Oh drugs this apparently drugs
buying my head - wait let me maybe I
should be over here Han I'm moving
myself no one panic God here we go there
I go I'm going on an adventure flip now
what is this I've got drugs up here I
don't know those before I guess nothing
I hate that oh well I can't be over here
now cuz if okay we're going back a
little bit a little what the [ __ ] is
this
no I just want to air this yes why we're
still making taking money from them know
what we're on um what the [ __ ]
okay can heal more furniture one more
defender defender what the [ __ ]
make our city clean what the [ __ ] hey
welcome to the job so it's actually easy
today's a trial day you ask if they need
a package and if they do you give it
[Music]
done and today we're making cheese
muffins 160 grams of count corn flour
120 grams of whole watts flour 300
milliliters of mark 150 grams of hard
cheese 50 grams of butter one teaspoon
of sugar I have the coconut 1 1 teaspoon
of slack soda pour 1 teaspoon of baking
powder
Sybil tips of flour and mix it together
add all the other drowing Grodin's moocs
melt the butter and stuff add new what
the [ __ ] dude what what darling muffin
farms preheat an oven to the 290 degrees
celsium baker muffins for 20 30 minutes
enjoy morning coming what the [ __ ]
there's an arrow behind my head start
the day for God's sake where's his
papers please you shouldn't sell
packages this is bad for all of us need
a packet here you go
thank you yes
okay you need a packet all right hang on
oh well thank you
you do need a packet I don't understand
anything that's god damn it well there
goes all I know there's a ten I put
those in there okay well it's unlimited
there it is
there's the five no that's the ten
hi what the [ __ ] that he was five what
I've got negative money now I've got
negative money what the [ __ ] what is
this game I fine I'll move hang on I'm
gonna move this there I guess I'm here
now
hey please ten here's your change
there's your change
and there's and that there's a change so
it's a it's a simulator of being a
cashier at a grocery store I'm gonna
keep going on it hello everyone it's all
today we're gonna continue making
rasgulla now softies we can either Rob
with receive or use blender I guess I
can't be here now I don't know I don't
know
I don't know after rubbing it we'll have
a nice soft mass use it to form balls
each what of okay Peter rasgulla grows
almost three times its size by three
litres of milk
make about ten fifteen pieces why am I
playing a board I've never seen a more
bizarre game than this game right here
I've never okay but I'm gonna stop being
flabbergasted by it I'm gonna through
sheer force of will I'm gonna stop being
flabbergasted by this and I'm gonna take
this [ __ ] seriously and I expect all
of you all of you to what happened to
the soup why is it black I expect all of
you to take it equally as seriously
because if you do not take this
seriously
this will not go well one day little
Carl did not get prize great story
thank you need packet no halva however
however however this is not enough you
need more money
more mud there we go smarts me have
money now think think think
okay now I've got it hate a packet oh
you need a pack away poop and put it in
put it in put it put it in the packet
put the packet up here have a packet
okay you got a packet coffee tea soap
dude and Dew and a packet got it okay I
got why don't I get one dollar for that
that's a hard this is hard feel like I'm
playing some horrible math blaster from
a different dimension I'm gonna stop
being flabbergasted I'm gonna stop being
flabbergasted I'm going to stop being
what is the appeal of this game honestly
I don't know I really don't know I don't
know what I'm doing I don't know why I'm
doing it I don't know if there's some
surreal other meaning to this game I I
really honestly truly don't understand
what is like what is the purpose of this
game obviously someone put a lot of work
in at the game this is like a health bar
of some kind
there's a lot of what's with the
barnacles
what is there's got to be like it
wouldn't just be this right I mean it's
kind of relaxing I guess at its best
it's relaxing
I still have negative seven dollars but
at like I guess it's kind of interesting
I need five Oh
all right I'm bailing
I'm bail bail bail bail bail hard
bailing hard on that one just I can't I
can't I can think of nothing even to say
I can't think of anything to do I have
no idea what that is about
I have no idea I have no idea but that
was neat a packet the name of the game
was need a packet no idea it looks
familiar
no I've played this one no no I put I
know I played this one this isn't
ringing any bells but it's kind of oddly
familiar
well is there an update
how did this happen is now how I'm meant
to be we were never meant to be married
would consider I played this [ __ ] [ __ ]
no I played this no I played this I've
played this how about play it again here
we go we're just gonna play through it
again why not having them fun level
level come on what's so bad about it
I love playing all classic everybody
plays games that they love over and over
again right what do I do
I don't know what I do do I do go to
sleep go nap okay we're gonna we're
gonna go to okay I got nothing
well I've that's new did that happen
before no what no that's no way what the
[ __ ]
[Applause]
the baby I remembered a baby I have
known I'm left here alone in the dark
rides keep me up at night why I won't -
shut up please make it shut up just shut
up Helen where are you oh I do I did
play this before I don't know if it's
been updated at all but hmm not sure
about that ah that's that's an issue
that's actually no good oh I probably
need this scared about take this hi I
don't remember that my god is squashed
oh [ __ ] oh I don't remember that I
remember that what is it new Helen is
pregnant we did not plan this why didn't
I use a goddamn condom or just such an
idiot
god dammit Oh what am I just dead in his
is just starting over or is it it was
that supposed to happen I didn't see an
escape well there was a key
oh wait wait is that the same way I died
before okay after this we're gonna go
back and we're gonna watch that video
together cuz I don't remember [ __ ]
any of this I don't remember a goddamn
thing here [ __ ] I don't remember this
it's like I remember contextually like
kind of this but it just all blurs
together with everything else how'd this
happen oh how did it happen
I put my penis in I took my penis out I
put my penis in again and then I shook
it all about and suddenly she's pregnant
I don't get it how does this happen
ah [ __ ] so the guy there was something
else that you gotta do we're gonna we're
gonna do we're gonna able to play
through this we're gonna play through
this
[Applause]
so what door am I supposed to unlock
with the key again I don't even know
okay I got this oh is it busy I guess no
it's the same I remember it now oh I
remember it
finally it is silent I thought doing
this would help me but I still cannot
sleep what have I done my mind is lost
without her I need you Helen
well maybe shouldn't it go dad baby hey
I see ya
I'm table for ya Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
oh [ __ ] off I didn't meow [ __ ] off and
[ __ ] you ah [ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] about I'm
out no no no no we're not watching that
we're gonna watch some wholesome
markiplier content
we're gonna watch something really
high-quality we're gonna a markiplier
video here we go oh yeah wait I remember
wait okay this one yeah there we go okay
what the [ __ ]
I remember that why did I do that and
then my name is markiplier and welcome
to hotel remorse [ __ ] creepy [ __ ] I've
ever seen in my entire life holy hell
who made this mask just having it look
at me anyway
horror game I don't need to explain
anymore let's play and I gotta move this
we're gonna do like a side-by-side
comparison of this alright me
here we go me all right you got this me
alright let's do this alright Saturday
October 2nd between the times of - you
know it's weird I look a lot more like
my brother right here in this in this
moment like I look a lot like my brother
and I don't know why like me and my
brother we kind of look similar but I
have like my dad's face my brother has
my mom's face like mine's longer face
and he has like a more rounded face but
right here I look a lot like my brother
between 2:00 and 3:00 a.m. there are
several reports ham Ming made what kind
of voices that you [ __ ] prick ah
Cubans of the hotel quickly what the
[ __ ] you doing stop being such a trihard
you piece of [ __ ] in search of safety
it's it for me what are you doing man
that you were talking about holy crap
yeah well as loud as balls that is true
we'll get through this and we will soon
be married having the rest of our lives
to be with one another and this baby and
this baby hey I guess babe a hotel I'm
turning my volume back up just because
just because
honestly my voice did change a lot over
the years and it's really weird to like
actually listen in on like an old video
of mine because it comes down to where
for a while there it wasn't natural like
cuz I was trying to do the thing where I
was projecting the projection was like
it was this weird feed but look I have
the exact same headphones I've been
keeping this headphones forever but it
was this weird moment where I was like
project and you just like encapsulate
this bizarre like announcer II voice
it's not like my voice didn't have
qualities that I wanted out of it it's
just like I was trying very hard like to
concisely do this cuz yeah but this is
only like what three years after I
started and it was just like I after the
incident of the Octodad after my voice
like intentionally changed and it took a
long time to fight out of that habit
like that was these are bad habits as
far as like vocal training goes so it
like I've learned a lot from this moment
what could happen also my mic now is way
better than them I mean my back might
back then and my audio processing is
much better than it was back then too so
I got a gun around here that's just a
bizarre thing cuz when i was recording
these like i knew that there was a
distinct difference from when I was like
recording recording and like when I was
talking and now it's like like I'm just
talking as I would normally talk but
this is super weird to like go back and
listen to this I remember that sound
effect that's a that's a I sound that's
a sound bite that a lot of people have
used maybe I've used that in the
compilation or something
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm a [ __ ] baby yeah and that's the
other thing like I would lose my voice
all the time because I was I was
speaking unhealthily when I was making
Let's Plays like I was speaking with way
too much pushing it was also a factor of
like I couldn't exactly hear myself now
I've got better monitoring software I've
got an audio interface that allows me to
hear myself at whatever volume I want I
can mix on-demand the volume of the game
versus the volume of my voice so I can
always hear myself like I'm turning my
own volume up in my headphones so I can
hear myself very clearly and when you
get in the feedback loop but when you
can't hear yourself you end up like
screaming because you're like you
naturally want to hear yourself so it's
just weird I can't really criticize that
because I do that all the time now
anyway I'm a mean man cuz my voices are
slightly better than yours [ __ ] Oh seems
to be leaking nightmares from the [ __ ]
was that what the [ __ ] did what was that
oh here I bet I die here see what he's
worried about he only shot a baby
maybe stop being such a [ __ ] about it
huh-huh you're so harsh of your pass
yeah exactly
yeah see that's all good that's all you
can be harsh about your past got any
regrets about anything that I've done
but it's just funny to watch like I
watch a lot of like my own videos
just to like self-evaluate like kind of
like get an idea of where I am and where
I where I've been I mean this was only
again this is only what three years ago
so it's not that long ago but it's like
yeah it's super weird it's slightly
better reaction times than this one that
I did the other one but oh yeah wait
wait there's a cheap jump scare coming
up enough of that back to business guys
back to business enough having fun
that's not what this is about
all right you guys just wasted your
opportunity because now it's time for
another break ha got them
[ __ ] me I hate myself dementia Mama's
home welcome to this one apparently this
is a PlayStation 4 like game meant for
that but I don't have a place as good
role I just got this Xbox controller so
we're gonna go with that over there but
I'm gonna see if it works with the Xbox
first actually maybe I should just do it
I dropped something okay I think if I
just play oh you think this is sacrilege
I've got an Xbox USB adapter and I'm
plugging it into a PlayStation do you
think this is gonna be utter sacrilege
probably do you think does this even
work I don't even know who's gonna work
you heard that no I don't hear anything
what happened doll okay well it worked
nope hey I restarted the game god damn
this [ __ ] the [ __ ] I go through to try
to give you guys a good experience when
it comes down to games I should have
just gone with the whatever here we go
all right we're going in again no
complaints it's all good it's all good
it's not working it's not working
wasn't even worth doing okay that didn't
work we'll put that I'm worried and
we'll just bust out why did I even try
why did I bother to try why did I try
was even the point of drying I was fine
everything was fine why did I try I just
needed to this is fine I bet I bet this
is gonna be fine here we are
spooky OOP there we go okay it does work
not parently all right here we go Oh
whoo
it looks good very nice I'm not sure why
they put this out on PC if who's
supposed to be a PlayStation demo maybe
they just need accessibility for it
other people to see it all right whoo
okay
why is everything so blurry oh my god
that hurts my eyes I'm super drunk
I believe I'm just gonna try to very
gently non-volley navigate through this
place okay do I need water or should I
turn this off X there we go sploosh ahh
cleared all the dust out of my eyeballs
now I can see good hello okay find the
key to my own front door why would I
need that why would that be a thing what
is this oh well found the key to my own
front door I guess hello
peekaboo what was
find and pick up the flashlight what was
that grandma grandma oh wait uh oh there
we go okay there we go
good god okay now I can move wait what
happened I'm now crouched why am i good
there we go okay I thought I was done
because I was pressing buttons on the
controller and it wasn't working but I
think we're okay
alright grab this I've got this push
what what's up what what what okay I
can't move I can't move okay I just
wanna play the game okay I want to turn
off this control I'm gonna turn off this
controller getting steamy up in here you
know yeah it's like you get one good
game experience out of like six bad ones
and it's just like man if like it's it's
almost as if there should be some way to
teach people how to make games properly
and now I'm being shitty about it now
I'm being shitty and now I'm being
shitty and you know what I don't give a
[ __ ] if I'm being shitty about it
because it's like it should be simple it
should be simple playing games should be
just the easy and simple and fun fun fun
games [ __ ] off
fun I can't move but I can press the
menu' bite this button brings up the
menu okay I don't know why suddenly the
Xbox controller broke but we're gonna
try this again
we're gonna try this again I'm gonna
plug the controller in directly and
that's gonna fix all my problems I
guarantee all my problems are about to
be false never mind
they are not I can't move with mouse and
keyboard I can only do this this is
working okay that works
just no longer works by restarting and
I'm not gonna be angry about it it's a
new opportunity a new opportunity to do
what the [ __ ]
suddenly I have motion controls enabled
pretty good game huh I break again I'll
get him here we go I'm gonna get him we
won yeah we won hell yeah guys I'm going
to throw up
I don't know what the [ __ ] is happening
here I don't know why the [ __ ] it's
happening but I can't play that game so
yeah yeehaw baby man and I wanted to
play that game it looked great the game
looked great but then it wasn't let's do
something else
let's try this one it's called Miss
eyesore so this is miss eyesore oh that
looks spooky this game couldn't it's
flashing images loud sounds a jump skirt
I like this out of that help the play I
don't like this free generator that
breaks your power level will decrease
even faster if your power reaches zero
lights will turn off in the game there
will be a map of the bunker complex on
the map at different generators or
listening the corresponding number oh my
god if any generator on the map starts
blinking that it is broken and needs
repairing the light on the flash faster
and faster as it gets closer to breaking
if the red lamp turns solid is broken
and beyond repair quickly close any door
leading to the fully broken generator if
you don't miss eyesore will come after
you remember the closing doors means
losing the generators for good but also
that you stay alive if you can afford
losing them close the door if a
generator is breaking the red light on
the generator will turn on and spin it
will also be sparks in noises so far it
is safe and you can repair it by
clicking and holding on it however it is
broken the lights on the ceiling that
are not flick will turn off as well as
the dinner head will stop making noises
miss eyesore will get into the dark room
soon after the generator breaks if you
sear don't say hi
controls walk-around of us needs sprint
by holding shift in Terraria with up
just weekly an essay is not good game
design all right let's do this cutter
get the generators 139 gotta make sure
they don't break but if they are
breaking then they got a break hello
hello hello is anybody there
I'm in charge of maintaining this bunker
there seems to have been a collapse in
the tunnels we will try to get you out
as fast as we can the connection to the
main seem to have gone out you will have
to keep the generators running if you
want to give the lights on we will be
through in just a few minutes just the
call was cut short all right read the
transcript I don't need to so whoa is
that about lights shining flashing that
seems bad so doors lock is that leads
out but it is locked
oh six don't look so good wait where am
I I'm here that's the right okay
is this a generator
bada-bing bada-boom baby did that okay
here so I did that and then okay one two
and three are going out dinner is fine
for now here we go
perfect okay so how do I know if miss
eyesore is coming after me like will I
have a clue or is she just gonna pop out
of nowhere oh okay
eight and seven no oh wait no wait which
one which way was eight oh no I went the
wrong way it's all down this wing okay
oops don't [ __ ] me then this one's fine
down here man why do they need nine
generators for this I mean if they're
all breaking down all the time what's
even the point of having them all right
oh you didn't close the door to
generator eight in time okay okay this
just okay whatever all right okay all
right here we go okay so I know this
game I only got to survive five minutes
there's a countdown in the top left okay
number five easy peasy
easy peasy easy peasy he's my position
I've got a lot of positions are good
have been known to have quality
positions
and nobody can argue that right okay
we're good okay this one is ski Pazuzu
key thumb zp zoom ski and MZ Pozos key
wasn't that what kind of we got a lame
excuses at that like these like I'm
trapped in here with all the generators
what are these powering besides just the
lights like this many generators like it
would have to be something dramatic well
that might be going out soon
what oh okay Oh oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] I'm closing that down so I
closed off that that other way but I
don't know if that was a good idea
because I might have lost those
generators but I think it's better just
to play it safe for this run nope that
one got it okay easy Pazuzu can I just
close this one too just because okay got
it
you're gonna get seven seven I'm on it
I'm on it babe
I'm on it I'm in it I'm in it to win it
no miss eyesore for me okay alright I
can't I can deal with this like game
play this game plays nice but loses the
instructions for it weren't too good
like you you do an escalating thing for
it if you wanted to nothing over here
number five don't break don't break
hello okay good good
and is this one breaking it seems like
it might be breaking yeah okay all right
I'm good I'm good baby I'm good at this
game oh why are you breaking again you
son of a [ __ ] do you think you this guy
turn my back and you can break you
stupid piece of crap oh man I'm gonna
run out of power so all those are broken
now we're looking at number eight okay
I'm coming to you baby
hey you think I would leave you behind
there's no [ __ ] there we go I'm just
gonna peek over here to make sure that
this one isn't breaking okay seems fine
okay I got this understand this is the
others going how we doing oh [ __ ] yeah
ain't gonna be good oh oh no way
nope no way not going down there okay
that's bad oh that's bad how the [ __ ]
dude oh god oh god oh god oh god
oh dear [ __ ] da [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
okay well I'm [ __ ] um I have this wait
I forgot to do [ __ ] off come on just let
me I have oh [ __ ] off
no [ __ ] I'm trying to show people
something stop right there
how'd you do that how would you do this
like it's that would be almost
impossible all right I'm gonna give it
one more try I'm gonna give it one more
try
and that's gonna be good I'm gonna I'm
gonna do it more by like when I'm in an
area I'm gonna listen cuz this feels
like it'd just be almost impossible get
by I'm going okay that seems fine I
guess I can look for like flashing
lights cuz if anything's flashing then I
out I would be guessing that oh I can
shift to run I wasn't sprinting oh well
it was broken okay so I wasn't sprinting
why would they have two modes why
wouldn't you always be going as fast as
you could go that just seems silly okay
you should always be going as fast as
you could should go oh my god oh my god
okay great
oh [ __ ] me then was this one okay this
one's okay oh you're fine why did I even
bother looking else who else who else
oh [ __ ] that's not good okay please okay
oh okay not that one
oh that's okay okay that's bad this
one's going down it's okay though mmm oh
yeah this is stressful
I will admit this game is very stressful
like very stressful okay close that one
down we're okay for now oh I'm off Elmo
it's better to lose this one than an
entire wing of them that's for sure
which is what I panicked did last time
okay okay one generator is now down
again but which one is it regenerate oh
of course it was the one farthest away
from where I was of course it was gonna
be that one why would it be anything
else that's fine for now sure it is okay
whatever you say
a okay I'm probably super behind on
everything
Boesky okay what else we got what am I
missing how am i failing I'm failing
like that you got it buddy I'm failing I
love it I love failing okay here we go
oh [ __ ]
do i do her
okay was that one fine was that one
broken okay was not broken but now it is
okay now it's broken
I think I think I might make it this
time I made me good oh no I might not
know I might not know I might not know
break break break
okay we're good okay got that one how
are you doing you good okay you good
okay what do we got eight eight and
seven okay
and what if you got oh you just did that
when did you do that okay you're good
I've only got a minute 45 left do I have
enough time to go down to five
yes no no no nope nope one one one
you're right - you're good - good okay
two's good okay so uh I seven and eight
why the farthest ones you sexist [ __ ]
okay I'm gonna go seven first just
because I can because I thought it was
gonna be I think that Wendy went down
first
yeah something else went down something
else broke of course
it broke oh no no I'm fine
let me get this one first never mind boy
won't let me try to go for this one
first less than a minute
ten percent power oh I'm [ __ ] yeah I
am [ __ ] I am exceptionally [ __ ]
I am bun believably [ __ ]
I am ludicrously [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] Doug close no nope hey whoa wait
wait that's hard
but good I like that the mechanic is
tight but mechanic is really good the
man mechanic is mechanics okay let's try
that again I think we can do that now
that I now that I don't know what I'm
doing now that I really know I just need
to be more efficient about the
directions that I go to get what I need
to get and now I know to run like the
whole time maybe it might be it might
behoove me to wait like for a few if I
know I'm gonna be running off into a
distance like just to see ya but I'm not
gonna do that I'm just gonna try to gun
it nine of nine eight of nine so one
just went down I got to pay attention to
that to eight of nine so one is down I
mean if another goes down then I got it
I gotta like inspect already did break
where did it break where did the brick
way to break a brick road got to down oh
[ __ ] well this is one where I got to
make a choice right well [ __ ] me oh [ __ ]
me it's already falling apart okay so
like as soon as you get one that's like
away from another it falls apart and
then everything goes to [ __ ] and oh god
damn it
oh [ __ ] me this got a core I saw that I
saw you miss I saw I saw you miss I tore
[ __ ] well lost one already I'm gonna
lose another one if I'm not careful
which I'm not if I lose this one eye guy
lose two of them please yes
I wanna another one went down oh [ __ ] me
oh go get go go through that [ __ ]
thing you [ __ ] [ __ ] okay two
minutes left we got plenty of power for
two minutes left that's pretty good
709 that's pretty good thing ones down
yeah oh twos down okay I'm gonna go to
eight first I think uh uh nine first I
think that other one went down just
before that so that's fine get this one
oh another one went down so this is
where things are gonna go bad because
things are gonna start Dhamma knowing
down and I won't be able to control it
[ __ ] no oh it was fine all goddamnit
okay well gonna have to live with that
one now oh [ __ ] [ __ ] okay
all right it wasn't broken when I walked
by before so why would he be broken now
this game is stressful I don't it's too
stressed - stress - stress - stress oh
well that's gonna be thoug that's gonna
bite me in the ass oh don't break don't
break don't break don't break don't
break oh it's gonna bite me my ass my
ass as is about a big bitten [ __ ] me one
minute left one minute oh [ __ ] both of
those just went down oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
that's down wait no did I [ __ ] your dad
[ __ ]
[ __ ] me [ __ ] I'm gonna run out of power
[ __ ] I'm so close no no not like this
not like this not like this not like
that's not like that's not like this not
like this oh never mind
not like this not like this not like
this you don't like this no like does no
[ __ ] ah titty sprinkles oh [ __ ] me
[Music]
as hard
oh well I'm gonna call it I'm gonna call
that one that was it for now we played a
great game in some pretty alright games
and then some bottom-of-the-barrel game
so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always see you
[Music]